when the strawberries are ripe it's
seasonal workers who come to these
fields in Belgium to pick them though
the conditions here are rosy elsewhere
in Europe seasonal workers from non-eu
countries often get a raw deal they
often housed in temporary shelters made
of plastic and cardboard the EU is
working on legislation to put an end to
the precarious conditions you may
remember the terrible situation in
Rosano and Italy there were migrant
workers were suffering very badly and
that was the impetus for this the new
rules voted on by M EPS include a
minimum wage to stop undercutting pay
and proper accommodation as well as a
maximum duration of stay if it passes a
parliamentary vote in twenty fourteen
countries would have two years to comply
however the UK would be an exception we
don't opt in normally on the areas of
immigration migration immigration so but
that isn't say we don't have a view at
least I have a view very strongly on the
sort of conditions in which seasonal
workers have to exist and have to work
and that's why I have supported the the
measures today some polish em EPS were
concerned about how the new rules will
affect their agreements with third
countries like Ukraine and Belarus many
colleagues in Eastern Europe may have
concerns that it's my job to switch
those concerns it's not about the volume
of migrants coming in it's about basic
conditions and that's the important
thing so for any colleagues who have
concerns they shouldn't have concerns
it's about ensuring that you don't have
extremes of exploitation EU countries
would have to carry out inspections and
employers breaking the rules would face
stiff penalties in the aim of bringing
an end to the cycle of exploitation